fashion or iq fashion you picked it
[Music]
hey guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay i'll go first i'm inspired by y2k
like i love barbie
i better not be wearing these heels for
nothing because my feet are numb so
i better be number one it's funny that
you mentioned barbie because as soon as
i saw you i was like bomb barbie like i
know
that's everything i've ever wanted okay
but i'm pretty sure
this outfit is fire yeah i know i really
like your outfit it just like it seems
very like sustainable and like i've
never seen that before
so this is a coffin purse which is like
super cute to me
because i got it in a costume shop i
like ravioli and i'm confident
you could do it smash your phone i could
do iq
you picked it no no no you picked it you
can't complain you picked it no yeah
you big fashion i can't okay don't watch
it why because it's women no it's not
good okay then let's play
i'm too like i guess i'll be like okay
listen up number one and you're gonna
bow down
um so i would put myself like middle to
top
what's wrong nothing i'm good
let's play i think that my style can
come off intimidating a little bit
because it's
like kind of dark and kind of opposite
in my personality
i personally think i should be at least
at one or two because
i really am confident my style for me
that's kind of like this old hollywood
vintagey
kind of style and that's what i really
enjoy since i'm already at number one
i'm gonna just stay here
i definitely was thinking that i had to
go above and beyond thinking that this
had to be
the world's best outfit but i had to
step back and think like what would i
wear on a daily basis so that people can
kind of get an idea of what i do wear
it's just so well done the colors just
go so well together you're definitely a
streetwear girl okay i'll say number one
number two number three in the plaid
number four coffin number five
y2k barbie i mean that's okay you're
entitled to your own
boring opinion
you could say you're entitled to your
own opinion but the fact that you
thought
boring has you not accepted that opinion
and that person is not entitled
you know i can't i hate the fake nice
thing that women do to each other
i'm really just not a fan of the whole
nice thing which is it
perfect like yeah okay
well that's just your opinion but
we're cool no [ __ ] you hate her
just because you're rachel 5. listen
this
this is not my lean whatsoever i don't
fall about fashion so
don't get me wrong it's really hard to
just go but i'm
it's really okay it's fine it's all
right and that someone as basic as
yourself would have raped me oh fine
i take it i take it it's okay
yeah that that nice that fake nice
you're talking to someone who shows up
to every video in the hoodie so
i'm not saying that it's not cute
because you're rocking a girl fire but
i would be caught dead
okay now they going in
now they're going in and i just like the
way the rest of them just
especially her you know what's going on
all right
are they gonna fight oh my god i'm in
the middle of this that's an awkward
giggle
that is fun not saying that it's not
cute because you're rocking a girl
fire but i would be caught dead like i
would just be walking around like
don't look at me like i don't know it's
cute but not my taste
totally you're gonna laugh when i say
this because it's so like
not normal but i feel like my outfit
today is so boring
so i feel like i kind of toned it down a
little bit because i was like maybe i
shouldn't show up in like a full ball
gown
i put myself first without at risk of
sounding arrogant we've got issa is two
three celeste four is
lex and five is haley okay so i would
put myself in number one
of course i think
i feel like my outfit today is so boring
of course i would put myself at number
one
because yeah where's my kim
like i will put myself like i'm so
boring it's boring but
hold on hold on really really really you
know what it's okay maybe i'm being
unfair
maybe i'm being biased we are unfair and
we aren't being
maybe they're not they're not dislikable
that's that's
you know what the problem is we're being
toxic that's us played a damn thing i
don't know who sent us this video for us
to react to
i regret it am i fine here or am i fine
at two
i personally like you it too how people
see me it's like you either love me or
you hate me and then
50 50 i'm just like right in the middle
yeah i don't want to be an author but
like it makes sense
can you put on your earmuffs
why don't you choose iq i checked out
you wanted to keep on going
that's on you it's your choice i didn't
know it was that i commit
i commit yeah you think you're the
married [ __ ] i'm married to the game
i don't yeah yeah yeah i could tell no i
could tell i could tell i could tell
this is therapy for me it's my therapy
session it's your lovely
counseling is necessary you love
language
hey man i'm not even gonna frustrate you
brother just give me stress bro
[Music]
all right so we're gonna do this ranking
yeah we're gonna use ranking is one
going to stay in one i think
right no yeah no no really not what i
think one flight is
yeah one five yeah it looks it's so like
clean
if you really like look at the details
and thought that she put behind that
outfit
it was so cohesive you know i'm actually
not a big fan of the pants right i like
everything
stuff i like yeah yeah the ones are cool
i like like barbie's outfit just because
it
definitely stands out like it definitely
pops and she fits it i don't like the
dress personally
i mean it stands out i mean like i'm
standing outside you know
i like it it stands out
this man looks like he's got rainbows
coming out of his butthole
talking about standing out bro i mean
every time he opens up lucky charms from
falling out
you know listen this might be the video
where we do the least amount of
commentary on i got
nothing insightful for y'all no no i'm
watching this
as flabbergasted and as confused as you
guys i just i'm just i just i checked
out i checked out a long time ago
let's keep on going let's rock you okay
the barbie girl she was super out there
in my opinion
it was just more like okay that's a
little too much for me
or i really like that for some reason
even though i i wouldn't normally
like it's like attractive and then with
the you know like coffin purse and the
rings and everything i think is cool the
aesthetic of booster's
outfit is a lot better than barbie's i
wish there was like another glove
really i think the glove kind of feels
yeah
i guess i think it is if you had two
clubs like gloves are boring
five i saw her fit and i was kind of
like i didn't i didn't think she was in
it i thought she was a part of like the
team
yeah she gives me like like teacher kind
of vibes yes
it just looked too much like mary
poppins for me and
did i just couldn't get into it i would
put you right too also i like it with
zebra
she has to be too though okay so can we
switch you
switch roti
all right you know what i can't
appreciate about this just objectively
speaking
i like how nothing has to do with their
looks and it is about what they're
talking about
i think that might be like the coolest
thing that i'm taking away from this
video is that they stayed on
brand and they did what they were
supposed to do okay you know you're not
you mean like how good they look yeah
because you know sometimes it's like
personality no you're rating them
because she's
sick yeah stop lying yeah this is just
about that
even the way the women rated themselves
seemed to be about the fashion so i
could appreciate
the integrity of the winner i agree
barbie because
i think black dress just did a little
bit more who she reminds me of is harley
quinn
that's what i was trying to think of the
whole time so yeah i think these you
should switch yeah they can switch yeah
are you guys cool with that yeah yeah
yeah yeah i think that's good i'm all
good with it
i like i like this cool yeah i think
this is a safe way i think this is cool
yeah yeah
[Music]
i like it went from short to tall yeah i
appreciate that
this might be one of the few times where
short people could stand up and be like
oh my god we're winning we're in first
yeah yeah we're good yeah like where the
podium makes you all equal
at height that's great
so i kind of thought like you guys are
gonna be like yeah she's hot like put
her up front
they're gonna be like she's way too much
like she's extra put her in the back
so i'm not surprised i went through
phases where i had
short buzzed hair i dressed like a
skater boy and now
she's just a skater boy yeah i've seen
some people go through
some different she said see you later
boy yeah
she wasn't good enough for her i would
have liked to place higher but at the
same time i'm
weirdly proud that i didn't because if i
placed last
by the girls and the guys then that's
kind of saying like i'm not everyone's
cup of tea
but there's a certain amount of people
that i can really relate to and i can
form a
solid solid peer group rather than
trying to appeal to everyone all the
time
okay we're not ready for everybody
hey salty so
we're not ready to eat for everyone that
don't two [ __ ] over there
yeah yeah yeah there's always a little
dose of salt you know yeah because high
blood pressure is good for you yes sir
because at the end of the day as long as
you're happy with what you're wearing
and then you're
super confident go ahead go on with your
day i like that everyone's style is so
different yeah
yeah and it's like we're all fired so
like you know we're all waiting like
the best all right here comes the fake
kumbaya stuff all right i'm gonna just
start all fire
i mean you guys were more boring than i
was but it's all fire
we're all fired hey you know what maybe
i'm crazy maybe you guys don't
if you disagree with me let me know
about the whole you know the girls being
nice to each other for no reason but
yeah what are your thoughts on
on fashion in general how do you
approach it because i feel like this is
a conversation for you that's why i
picked this video uh
it really depends like i just wear what
i think is hot but i think it's dope
i wear things that are often practical
you know people
like i'm wearing this leather jacket is
not just for style it's because
it's protective there's a dorsal thing
it's for when i'm riding or anything
like that
uh what about your bulletproof vest my
bulletproof vest
which one
[Applause]
you're just talking like i only have one
just let them know the weight of this or
which one
oh yeah the other one it's really just
when i when i ride i mean i got a vest
why
i got different vests when i ride it's
protective like there's there's
dorsal stuff like that and whatever it's
just it's just riding gear that's like
it's practical the shoes that i have
motorcycle shoes i have
this to let's say if i crash they'll be
able to extrude me out of
uh the t-rex right like they're gonna be
able to pull something to pull instead
of just a shirt whatever
so i try to i try to
match what's as an intuitive
and also fashion and things that i think
is dope a lot you know it's just
really that and yeah it's really that
all right cool that's how i approach it
um the video was trash just kidding it
wasn't trash it was just
it wasn't for us it was not for us
that's it it was not it was no
i wouldn't say that it was trash it was
just okay was somewhat interesting i
guess it's people rating
them it's just the fashion and you're
young that i'm
pretty sure this video would be
interesting and i do like it in the fact
that yeah
the people they got were cool i like
that they did a good job
that i like thought i can't even kudos
to jubilee yeah kudos for jubilee
for they did a good job on that so that
that's great that's great
i wouldn't say that it's trash that was
a joke you don't use the word trash too
much you know
that no i use it just enough you don't
use it enough
you want to use it but you're like i
just want to be righteous i can't use it
because
i don't want to i don't want to call
nobody trash because i don't believe
that
no there's some [ __ ] out there
that are trash okay they belong in the
bin
yeah okay if you if you're saying what
my ego wants to say then i agree if you
ask me what i actually really want to
believe or what i do believe on the
inside
i think no i don't i know but we i don't
believe that either
yeah that's an old whatever
[Music]
me